[Musique]
avant tout était super génial
aujourd'hui tout est super mais j'étais
à porter à café du café ce liquide amer
qui fournit le seul semblant de plaisir
qui nous reste dans sept centres et pas
trop désolé je teins theron alors que tu
te demandes
les temps changent et tu dois changer
pour s'adapter
il faut qu'on soit dur est prêt à se
battre regard d'une étoile filante
fillon
la porte d entrée
j'ai même fait de plus en plus froid et
m qu'est ce que tu vois c'était pas si
grave rien est entré je suis général
mais m
amenez moi votre chef vous redoutable
tout était de ma faute
accroche toi tu es feuilles plantier on
est parti pour ce haut fait mieux
[Musique]
tu permets que je peux souffler mais en
restant prix ce qui es tu je m'appelle
rex tel geste et on sort de la galaxie
archéologues cowboy et dresseur de
raptor j'ai pas compris
est-ce que tu va m'aider à sauver mes
amis je te conseille de pâtes approché
du système soeur star il est dirigé par
une reine extraterrestre seuls les plus
durs orwell chance de s'en sortir
vivants si le gentil garçon qu'il est
gentil garçon je suis la reine doigté
brawne abbie je sens des ondes hyper
démoniaque et je peux prendre une autre
apparence si ça vous met plus à l'aise
que veut on veut changer le cheval était
beaucoup plus satisfaisant non pas du
tout c'est une des maîtres à temps tout
est dessiné des poils de bâle iii puis
non
[Musique]
je suis ton pire cauchemar c'est moi
j'ai en retard pour l'école que j'ai
oublié mon cartable et que mon pantalon
et en guimauve n'ont pas tout